on a small island in russia stands a 300
year old multi-dome church that was
built entirely without nails
[Music]
khizai island is home to two wooden
churches
and an octagonal bell tower that
exemplify 18th century russian
architecture
the largest building on kaza island is
the church of the transfiguration
120 feet tall and covered in 22 domes
the church sparkles like silver when the
sun hits it
it was a tradition in russian carpentry
to build using only wooden logs with
interlocking corners and no nails or
steel reinforcement
the structure was sturdy enough to
survive until the 19th century when it
underwent restoration to return it to
its former glory
in 1990 the island was listed as a
unesco world heritage site and today the
island is a national open air museum
it might just be a legend but upon
completion of the structure it was said
kazai's main builder cast his axe into
the water and proclaimed
there was not and will not be another
one to match it
[Music]
just over 30 miles away from the
slovenian capital
this alpine lake looks like it belongs
on the cover of a storybook
[Music]
with a fairytale cliffside castle an
emerald green freshwater lake and views
of some of the highest peaks of the
julian alps lake bled and its island
church make a postcard perfect scene
to visit the assumption of mary church
you must catch a ride on a wooden boat
known as a plenta
plentis have been taking visitors to the
island in the middle of the lake for
centuries
[Applause]
once reaching the island it's a 99 stone
step climb to reach the entrance to the
church
it is said that if a groom could carry
his bride up these steps and ring a
wishing belt at the top
the marriage would be a happy one
the church is most famous for this bell
which was made in the early 16th century
and is said to be a gift from the pope
[Music]
legend has it this was the church's
second bell
the first was bought for the church by
an inconsolable widow in honor of her
late husband who was murdered and then
thrown into the lake
when boatman brought it across to the
church an unexpected storm hit and the
bell sunk to the bottom
it is said if you listen closely in the
dead of night you can hear the sunken
bell ringing from the depths of this
picturesque lake
[Music]
okanoshima island is a short 12-minute
ferry ride from hiroshima region of
japan
while the sandy and palm line beaches
are perfect for holiday makers the
island draws crowds for a different
reason
rabbits
lots of them
and how they got there is a mystery
[Music]
between 1929 and 1945 the japanese army
secretly produced over 6 000 tons of
poison gas on okanoshima island some
believe the current rabbits are
descendants of those brought to the
island to test the gas but the current
director of the poison gas museum
insists these bunnies have nothing to do
with those from the world war ii era
so where do they come from
[Music]
[Music]
so those rabbits were released and with
no real predators they bred like
well
like rabbits
and yet another theory
either way this new generation of feral
rabbits has the run of the land they're
creating a new story separate from the
sordid past of okonoshima island an
island once known for death is now known
for possibly the cutest thing ever
bunnies
[Music]
stepping onto socotra island is like
setting foot on an alien landscape
this place is one of the most isolated
landforms on earth
located in the arabian sea south of
yemen the islands separated from the
mainland of africa between 6 and 7
million years ago
[Music]
there are nearly 700 endemic species on
sakota that are found nowhere else on
the planet
perhaps the most head-turning of
socotra's species is the dragon's blood
tree
these strange umbrella-shaped trees dot
the island
its top-heavy design is actually an
adaptation to socotra's arid climate the
large green crown provides shade which
reduces evaporation in a place that sees
very little rainfall
this otherworldly gem has experienced
threats to its ecology from human
development but the united nations
stepped in in 2008 designating it a
unesco heritage site
[Music]
what do you say to people who just say
this is not a normal way of living
thank you very much
[Music]
i'm katherine and this is my husband
wayne i'm wayne and welcome to freedom
code
[Music]
we live in a secluded cove
the only option we have to get here is
by water there are no road accesses
the water is our highway
[Music]
everything that you see here
in our home is floating
we are tied to shore with lines we are
not anchored
we have our main living house
we have the dance floor
the lighthouse building
four greenhouses
as i started to grow the garden and make
it larger then we had to have
more space for that garden
everything's done with a hand saw and
hammer
no power tools i know every board and
nail by name
it's about 500 tons
a million pounds when i'm flowing
i've been building tree forts since i
was seven
and i said well dad i'm putting a tree
fort in the ocean do you ever get
seasick
no when i go to town i get landscape
the thing about living in clockwood
sound on the west coast of vancouver
island it's the richest biomass on earth
so the opportunity to fish for dinner is
big
and i just can get in my canoe and
paddle out in 10 minutes i can catch a
fish
but when it's windy and too too rough
out there i can lay on the couch and
fish out of the house
i was hoping to make a lot more money as
an artist
so subsistence living was our only
opportunity to have anything as artists
we could never buy real estate so we had
to make our own
it was a great opportunity to actually
move away from the city to see if we
could
prosper out here
now 24 years later we're still doing it
i can't imagine living any other way
i feel completely fulfilled
oh that's good
that's really nice
i'm working on it
[Music]
coastal at one moment
isolated island at another
malsi michelle is incredibly stunning no
matter the tide
[Music]
in between two powerful tides from
normandy and brittany stands the
gothic-styled benedictine abbey named
after and dedicated to the archangel
saint michael
moncey michelle wasn't always an island
in prehistoric times it stood on dry
land however as sea levels rose erosion
reshaped the coast
even today it only sits 600 meters from
land
although it has less than 50 full-time
residents it is visited by more than 3
million people each year
the climb to see the abbey isn't easy
it's around 900 steps
more than just a church on a rock masa
michelle is a medieval time capsule and
was one of the first monuments to be
classed as a unesco world heritage site
back in 1979
[Music]
you